Moïse ne croyait pas en Dieu ?!
La Bible n’est pas un livre monothéiste
?!
Ce sont deux des nombreuses affirmations étonnantes
du livre « Qui est Dieu ? » de Jean Soler,
dont je vais vous résumer les idées principales.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
J’ai choisi de lire ce livre quand j’ai
eu vent de la polémique suscité par Michel
Onfray à son propos.
C’est dans un texte publié dans l’hebdomadaire
Le Point en 2012 que le philosophe avait créé
la controverse en présentant l’auteur comme
un héros intellectuel luttant contre l’hégémonie
monothéiste.
Jean Soler est un ancien diplomate qui se
consacre désormais à l’étude des monothéismes,
à propos desquels il a déjà écrit plusieurs
ouvrages remarqués.
Celui-ci, c’est un peu la synthèse de tous
ses travaux antérieurs.
Je précise à ce stade que mon intention
n’est pas du tout d’entrer dans la polémique,
ni de donner mon avis.
D’ailleurs, mes connaissances en théologie
sont plutôt rudimentaires ; donc je ne prétends
certainement pas faire pencher la balance
dans un sens ou dans l’autre.
Je souhaite simplement proposer une synthèse
efficace de ce livre parce que je l’ai trouvé
intéressant.
Alors, quelles sont les révélations fracassantes
qu’il contient ?
Comme d’habitude, j’ai retenu 3 idées.
Pourquoi Jean Soler dit-il que Moïse ne croyait
pas en Dieu ?!
Parce que Moïse croyait en UN DIEU PARMI
D’AUTRES !
Petite précision : si vous ne le savez pas,
Moïse c’est le 1er prophète du judaïsme,
celui qui a reçu la loi pour cette religion.
Je reviens à la confusion monothéisme-monolâtrie.
D’après Jean Soler, à lire l’Ancien
Testament dans un hébreu rigoureux, il apparaît
que le Dieu de la Bible est un parmi d’autres.
D’ailleurs, il a un nom (« Yahvé ») qui
permet de le distinguer des autres.
La traduction par « le Seigneur » ou « l’Éternel
» dissimule la dimension nationale des dieux
de cette époque.
Par exemple, dans le 1er commandement : « Tu
aimeras un seul Dieu », Yahvé demande d'être
vénéré à l'exclusion des autres dieux.
C’est ça, la monolâtrie.
Jean Soler interprète cela comme la volonté
des auteurs de la Bible de combattre les divinités
concurrentes.
En fait, d’un point de vue historique, les
Juifs n’étaient très probablement pas
encore monothéistes quand le premier noyau
de l’Ancien Testament a été écrit, à
la fin du VIIème siècle avant J.-C.
C’est tout simplement nous qui projetons
sur les hommes de l’Antiquité nos croyances
monothéistes modernes.
Mais alors, comment a bien pu apparaître
le dieu unique ?
La première chose à prendre en compte, c’est
que Jean Soler étudie la question à partir
de l’histoire matérielle des peuples.
Du coup, il se méfie pas mal des récits
religieux…
Son explication à lui, elle est un peu darwiniste
: ce serait la pression des circonstances
historiques subies par le peuple juif qui
serait à l’origine du passage au monothéisme.
En clair, comme ses croyances ne correspondaient
plus à la réalité, le peuple juif aurait
fait évoluer sa religion.
Quelles sont-elles, ces circonstances historiques
si particulières ?
Ce sont précisément 3 malheurs qui ont rendu
nécessaire l’adaptation théologique :
1° tout d’abord, la scission au sein des
douze tribus mythiques d'Israël après la
mort du roi Salomon ;
2° ensuite, la déportation de la population
juive de l'Assyrie vers la fin du VIIIe siècle
avant J-C ;
3° enfin, la conquête de la Judée et la
destruction de Jérusalem par le roi babylonien
Nabuchodonosor.
Or, le peuple juif avait normalement fait
alliance avec le plus grand des dieux…
D’après Jean Soler, les prêtres, les prophètes
et les scribes auraient donc réagi dans l'imaginaire
en forgeant des explications ex post et en
les mettant par écrit.
Ils seraient mis à imaginer que Yahvé aurait
utilisé d'autres peuples pour punir les Hébreux,
puis qu’il aurait ensuite châtié ces peuples-là.
C’est comme si cette vidéo n’était vue
par personne, et que je disais après coup
: « C’est parce que Dieu veut me punir
pour avoir parlé du livre de Jean Soler.
Donc selon Jean Soler, ce sont les échecs
répétés du peuple juif à s’imposer face
aux autres peuples qui sont responsables du
passage au monothéisme.
Alors, bien sûr, cette mutation de l’idée
de Dieu ne peut pas être datée avec précision,
parce qu’elle a été très progressive.
En tout cas, cette nouvelle version s’est
répandue bien efficacement parce qu’elle
simplifiait le dogme et qu’elle constituait
un puissant facteur d’unification dans l’Empire
romain.
Cependant, le monothéisme a aussi des défauts,
tout particulièrement un…
Si Jean Soler en veut au Dieu unique, c’est
parce qu’il pousse à tuer en son nom.
Il y a bien le commandement « Tu ne tueras
point », mais en l’interprétant à l’aune
de la monolâtrie - c’est-à-dire Yahvé
comme le dieu national des Juifs - eh bien
ça voudrait plutôt dire « Tu ne tueras
point LES MEMBRES DE TON PROPRE PEUPLE…
mais les autres tu peux ».
Concernant la violence, Jean Soler rappelle
qu’elle était très courante dans le monde
du peuple juif de l’Ancien Testament.
On trouve d’ailleurs dans ce livre l’ordre
de mettre à mort, dans le récit du Veau
d’or, quand Dieu ordonne à Moïse de tuer
tous ceux qui ont adoré le veau en or comme
un dieu.
En pratique, la peine de mort était répandue
dans la loi judaïque.
Moïse était plus généralement un mec assez
peu tolérant : il a enjoint son peuple à
exterminer les peuples rivaux parce qu’ils
ne peuvent pas cohabiter sur la même terre
; et puis le passage au monothéisme a demandé
d’anéantir les croyances et les représentations
des autres dieux.
Enfin bon, il n’y a pas que le judaïsme
qui soit violent.
Malgré son message fondamental sur la non-violence,
le christianisme est devenu violent à partir
de l’alliance de l’Église et du pouvoir
politique dans la seconde partie du 1er millénaire
après J.-C.
Les croisades, la chasse aux sorcières, etc.
tout ça est bien connu.
Mais là, on arrive à un des points les plus
controversés du livre.
Selon Jean Soler, la violence monothéiste
aurait été recyclée dans les totalitarismes
du XXe siècle, qui ne seraient en fait que
des variantes mentales sous-jacentes du monothéisme.
En effet, on parle souvent du nazisme et du
communisme comme de religions séculières
(cette idée est due à Raymond Aron, me semble-t-il).
Là où Jean Soler a fait encore plus fort,
c’est qu’il a rapproché le judaïsme
et le nazisme…
De son point de vue, le « peuple élu » de
Moïse, ce sont les Allemands pour Hitler
; le séparatisme juif renvoie à la pureté
de la race allemande ; et il avance même
qu’Hitler aurait, dans un certain sens,
retourné contre elle l’idéologie venue
de Jérusalem.
On peut comprendre que ces idées n’aient
pas plu à tout le monde…
En tout cas, pour Jean Soler, le monothéisme
est intrinsèquement intolérant, quand le
polythéisme ignore par nature l’intolérance
religieuse.
Il en appelle donc à « l’esprit d’Athènes
» pour lutter contre la violence monothéiste
qui semble ressurgir au XXIème siècle avec
la recrudescence des attentats.
Alors, en synthèse, pourquoi ce livre est-il
intéressant ?
Parce qu’il propose une interprétation
claire, rationnelle et originale de l’émergence
du monothéisme.
Ses qualités ?
Il est court, clair et extrêmement pédagogique.
Il met en relation les croyances religieuses
et l’histoire matérielle.
Et Il fait une critique plutôt courageuse
des religions, un peu dans la tradition des
philosophes des Lumières.
Ses défauts ?
Sur le fond, on peut lui reprocher d’avancer
des idées trop grosses pour être vraies
- mais bon, moi je suis bien incapable de
trancher.
Sur la forme, on peut lui reprocher son ton
pamphlétaire
Et enfin, il y a quand même beaucoup de redites
dans ce livre de synthèse...
Je pense qu’il y a eu pas mal de copier-coller
- mais bon, on a bien le droit de s’auto-plagier
!
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de Qui est Dieu ? de
Jean Soler sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale, voire pour pour lire l’ouvrage
lui-même, les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.